francisco lima salsa or chico as he's
called lives in the heart of Brazil's
Amazon rainforest he's 61 but can still
climb up an acai tree in the blink of an
eye the fruit is too green he says so he
slides down without it he also grows
kokoa used for making chocolate manioc
beans and raises chickens we're living
in an era in which we don't need to
think about wealth but about survival
if you have enough to buy shoes you can
produce food which are the essentials
along with health you can live well
chico is one of the founders of a
sustainable development settlement here
in an apple there are a hundred and
sixty families who live off the forest
without destroying it but this oasis is
being increasingly ravaged this is what
the untouched Amazon rainforest looks
like almost impenetrable and just across
the road here is the perfect example of
what Brazil's president calls opening up
the Amazon for economic development and
progress protecting the forest from
illegal loggers and cattle farmers is
dangerous chico takes us to see the
charred remains of what was the
settlements community center the land
grabbers wanted to take our land and
thought if they burned down our
community area we wouldn't be able to
rebuild again and leave nineteen people
have been murdered here in an apple and
killings related to land disputes chico
shows us where he was stabbed a few
years ago the knife pierced his lung
with only three environmental agency
officers assigned to an area larger than
all of england it's almost impossible to
protect the community
or the forest says para state prosecutor
who beat a tan casita the illegal
activities that impact the environment
such as mining and logging are done in
the most remote areas where the local
power structure is linked to criminals
and now we have severe budget cuts for
policing along with the government
discourse that encourages illegal
activities most of the members of the
Kim
unity were too afraid to appear on
camera but Chico remains defiant even so
you don't have to look far to see that
at least for now he's losing the battle
to preserve his rainforest you see a
human at JC de Anna poo Brazil